un sommet auquel la rt france n'a pas pu
participer on retrouve à montpellier
samantha ramsamy
bonsoir samantha l'accréditation
d'arreter france a été refusé
alors oui nous avons été refoulé à
l'entrée presse du nouveau sommet
afrique france malgré notre inscription
il y a plusieurs semaines nos
accréditations n'ont pas été acceptées
l'agent en charge des médias nous a
indiqué le motif suivant pas
d'accréditation pour des raisons de
sécurité sur décision de la préfecture
l'actualité ici à montpellier outre ce
rendez-vous au sud france arena avec ce
nouveau sommet afrique france et bien
c'est aussi un contre sommet à
l'initiative de collectif d'associations
et de militants l'objectif c'est de
lutter contre l emmo persistant de la
françafrique dans son ensemble c'est ce
sont des manifestations durant plusieurs
jours qui semble déranger les autorités
puisque jeudi plusieurs militants de
défense des sans papiers ont été arrêtés
à la gare à de montpellier à leur
descente du train en provenance de paris
il faut savoir que manifestation est
prévue ce samedi et je vous propose
d'écouter l'une des participantes
mireille fanon mendès-france la fille de
frantz fanon l'une des figures de la
lutte anticoloniale
il ya quelque chose aussi d'un peu
désinvolte de la part de ce président
qui est de faire un sommet france
afrique et dans le club un brin sommet
afrique-france pardon et d'en faire un
tel battage en une journée prend-il
pouvoir renégocier ou revisiter la
relation afrique france ont une journée
personne peut faire cela donc on ne peut
pas
prétendre que ce sommet va régler quoi
que ce soit si ce n'est qu'on a ce qu
une fois de plus le fait que la france
veut continuer sa sa relation
commerciale et financière et en tirer le
plus de bénéfice et pour ça ils
utilisent la diaspora qui elle même est
dans quelque chose d'ambigu lui aussi et
pour revenir samantha sur le sommet
officiel afrique france il a été marqué
par un dialogue plutôt franc avec la
jeunesse et des annonces attendues sont
sûr présents
oui lors de se sauver ce nouveau sommet
plutôt afrique france et bien c'est vrai
qu'il ya quand même eu un dialogue franc
entre la jeunesse et emmanuel macron
c'était de toute façon annoncé et
attendu les jeunes qui ont interpellé le
président français sur des
problématiques importantes comme la
démocratie la question migratoire mais
aussi les tensions avec l'algérie et
plusieurs pays du maghreb après la
décision française de réduire
drastiquement elle les visas sur la base
des travaux effectués par l'historien et
politologue camerounais achille 20 b le
chef de l'état a fait plusieurs annonces
il a annoncé la restitution du
patrimoine africain au bénin notamment
et puis la création d'un fonds de 30
millions d'euros pour la société civile
pour soutenir les démocraties en afrique
alors ce n'est pas l'état français qui
va fixer les bénéfices ya ce sera un
comité composé de personnalités de
membres de la diaspora on va quand même
attendre de voir qui sont ses membres
qui seront ses membres quels sont les
réseaux dont ils seront issues pour
déterminer la transparence et la
véritable indépendance de ce futur
comité ce que l'on peut dire pad annonce
finalement fracassante susceptibles de
réellement bouleversé la donne pour
refonder la relation afrique france
merci beaucoup pour ce compte-rendu
samantha ram famille envoyée spéciale à
montpellier pour ce sommet afrique
france